[Musique]
bonsoir il ya eu l'année de la femme il
ya eu l'année de l'enfant 1982 a été
désigné en lieux pour être l'année des
cons je me trouve ce soir chez le
professeur m'a collé du char qui a été
choisie en haut lieu pour organiser pour
superviser cette année des cons alors
tout d'abord professeur merci de nous
recevoir chez vous que je vous instruis
est alors j'imagine que si vous avez été
désigné pour assumer cette lourde
responsabilité cette émission importante
c'est que vous êtes vous-même tricot il
s'agirait rien disons simplement que je
suis un vrai con sacrément content si
vous préférez la première question que
tout le monde se pose c'est comment font
les cons bien que votre question ne soit
pas particulièrement comme de je vais
tâcher d'y répondre
voici la carte kono graphique de la
france qui nous montre assez clairement
la répartition géographique des coûts
dans l'hexagone en rouge
vous voyez le département à forte
densité de cons en jaune les
départements à moyenne densité envers
les départements à cette densité que nos
graphiques sinon contart cette carte à
celle de la répartition démographique
que constatons nous nous constatons
qu'en france c'est dans les départements
les plus peuplés qu'on rencontre le plus
petit bien qu'on peut dire qu'au niveau
de la spécificité so lu ment
d'ailleurs le conte n'est pas immuable
il me gratte comme le montre cette
troisième carte nous voyons ici
la répartition kono graphique estivale
de la france il était en effet l'écho
rejoignent du littoral par ordre très
serré
s'agglutinent teint si pour ne pas
perdre ne fût ce qu'un mois par an la
chaleureuse promiscuité de la ville ils
forment un conglomérat continue de
calais à hendaye et de port vendres à
nice audit alors qu'ils sont un peu con
sur les bancs oui alors seconde question
que se posent tous les gens qui nous
regardent professeur magri du chat c'est
à quoi reconnaît-on les cons à sa façon
de s'habiller
avant ça disons que c'est le meilleur
moyen pour ne pas se tromper
ah oui comment comment s'y prend on doit
préciser ma part c'est très simple
mettez dix personnes dans une pièce
observer les biens sur ces dix personnes
il y en a au moins une qui est habillé
comme les neuf autres
c'est un conte est ce qu'on peut faire
ce qu'un conte peut-être déconner fier
c'est pour ainsi dire impossible
même s'il est pris à temps à l'heure
actuelle si on est déçu à tout disant
qu'une fois sur cent il peut être traité
de quoi de cons de quoi oui c'est un
film
effectivement à vous entendre
protestants dans l'impression que cette
année des consonances très mira il ne
faut pas mettre la charrue avant les
boeufs comme on dit chez nous mais en
effet je touche du bois ça me semble pas
mal parti quels sont les grands
événements qui vont marquer cette année
d'école les événements habituels de ce
côté là nous n'avons pas changé grand
chose par rapport aux autres années où
tout s'est toujours très bien passé pour
nous nous ne reconnaissons donc c'est
plutôt sur le plan culturel que nous
avons fait un très gros effort puisque
nous allons inaugurer le musée des cons
un musée immense qui montrera toutes les
oeuvres réalisées par les cons depuis 20
ans c'est énorme
oui on s'aperçoit que c'est considérable
bien plus qu'on ne pouvait le penser
et quel sera le prix d'entrée alors de
ces salles 500 francs pour les cons 10
pour les autres je ne vous cache pas que
nous espérons faire une belle fête qui
me sera d'ailleurs intégralement remise
pour être sûr qu'elles ne sont pas
intelligemment dépenser
place il serait trop con après tous les
efforts que ne se font déployés pour
organiser cette année alors je crois
qu'on peut dire quand même processeur
que tout a été prévu jusque dans le
moindre détail pour que cette année dès
qu'on dise à 181 2 soit une réussite
absolument totale sur tous les plans je
vous remercie et professeurs makudi du
char notamment il me reste plus là vous
êtes trop con l'ordre heymans et l'année
[Musique]